[Music]
hey
all right oh that's so nice
[Music]
time travel is weird
mm-hmm
[Music]
oh it's almost exactly what harry potter
says
it wasn't my dad who saved me it was me
it was me hermione
oh this is nice though i like this it is
sweet welcome back to new rock stars
miss marvel episode 5 takes the already
thinly defined time travel logic of the
mcu after avengers end game and loki and
shatters it into a beautiful trail of
stars
but who's been saving her own nani it's
been kamala all along
this is inside marvel it's new
rockstar's official miss marvel after
show my easter egg breakdown for this
episode it's coming tomorrow
right now i'm eric boss and i am here
discussing this episode with mt hey hey
hey man it was so cool going back in
time and then seeing the whole trail of
stars moment i really like that and like
it's
like is it implied that like the actual
trail of stars is actually aisha like is
she like the stars itself because like
when when um when her husband saw it she
was like is that aisha i don't know it
was just very interesting but like yeah
i love the whole flashback sequence my
thinking it was that like the uh the
disc that she made disintegrated and
then uh sana was able to hold on to it
or at least
like it wasn't just kamala making the
trail of stars although she was taking
credit for it at that moment she was
like it was me no one else i didn't have
any
i didn't i'm not sharing the credit with
anyone i did this alone only i could fix
the past and allow for my own existence
no i think like it was it was a mixture
of an accident the the whatever the hard
light the nord disintegrating maybe
aisha and sana some mixture i like to
think like all generation of uh con
women are are
playing a part and helping each other
out to me thematically that's the most
beautiful way to interpret it like
they're all just kind of saving each
other they're all looking out for each
other i do like that uh i think
logically this isn't this is a familiar
thing this whole idea of going back in
time to save yourself this idea of a
closed loop predestined time travel i
saw a lot of people saying like we've
never seen this before this is a
completely new version of time travel
it's like maybe if you've only watched
avengers end game and if so only the
first two thirds of it but this whole
idea of uh predestined time travel is
actually i think becoming the
most common form of time travel fiction
uh but this is one of the sweeter
versions i think i've seen i did love
how they handled it and i think that's a
credit to the writing on this show and
the focus on kamala's relationship with
her mother and her mother's relationship
with her mother and that mother's
relationship with her mother i think
that is uh one of the purest most
wholesome parts of the show and and uh
despite like any kind of weird uh tonal
shifts as it has moved as the show has
moved from jersey city to karachi i
think it has lost a bit of something i
really loved those first two episodes is
how much we learned about jersey city
and the community of jersey city uh and
i i think there has been i don't know
how how to describe it i i just kind of
missed that part of the world i miss
seeing kamala with bruno i there's just
i i'm excited to go back there i assume
for the finale but despite all that one
thing that has stayed really great is
the the deeper we've gone into kamala
and her mother and uh right and muniba's
relationship with sana i think that's
just been really sweet um i i do think a
lot of it was kind of healed by the end
of last episode i don't know how much
more healing we needed this episode but
whatever whatever like i don't mind
redundancy as long as what we're getting
at double dipping of is something sweet
and wholesome right no i really love the
whole family ties of this series and
like i i really want to see
um kamala's grandmother use the bangle
in episode six like i just want to see i
want to see all of them use the bangle
like i want to see what her mom's powers
look like because like i know that she
has like that potential in her probably
so like yeah i sort of want to see like
a turning red type of moment where like
it's like yeah we've all got a type of
power like that'd be really fun
yeah do you think we're gonna get a
moment like where they uh
what's it called the annexation of
puerto rico maneuver from uh the little
giants where they just keep passing the
bangle from each other to person to
person and then each generation of con
woman uses the bangle to blast somebody
until it goes back onto the ghost of
aida
she's like it's my turn now
i'm still stabbed in ghost form oh
that's really sad but anyway i was
but i'm back and they're like oh we're
gonna hang out with a ghost now
the ghost grandma oh man all right let's
quickly recap what happened this episode
this episode takes us back to
pre-partition india um and it shows us
how aisha met kamala's grandfather
hassan by fleeing the british soldiers
with the bangle and then uh sleeping in
his rose garden now we gotta say aisha
kind of goes from bad to good she has a
bit of a smile on her face when she
stabs that british soldier now i'm not
saying the british occupiers didn't
deserve a bit of uh
you know that kind of treatment but
she's just enjoying it a little bit too
much i think
she was like i liked doing this
but then she tramples on hassan's roses
uh and uh but she stays and she stays
out there and then she gets to know him
he takes her inside he recites a poem by
a uh i believe it was a 13th century
persian poet rumi
and then she got instantly pregnant
after that poem oh for sure immediately
she's like i don't even finish giving
your babies bleeding
[Laughter]
gentlemen for you guys
i know it sounds like a cliche but
reciting poetry
that's all it really takes so it takes i
mean sometimes that poetry can just
simply be uh a dashboard confessional
lyric really exactly girl it always it
always works every time that's what i
that's why
it works um it works every time
[Laughter]
hey you're just
hey she's out there empty she's waiting
i don't know how i can i think this is
the episode now
dashboard confessional is always failing
me this is not inside mt this or this is
inside mt
now it is inside mt well we're just
talking about you guys
someone's gotta go with something
everybody that's that sounds weird don't
say
that
anyway
um okay so as the partition begins
muslims in this community are especially
screwed they're forced to leave their
homes uh and najma tracks aisha down uh
she just wants a bangle she's like
uh-huh i don't care where you hit it you
have until sunset tomorrow and then i
will kill you and your family um and
aisha leads us on its sauna just a
little too fast to the train station
like what's the rush
i understand we're being forced to leave
our homes but you're running a little
too fast it's not like we had
mobs with with pitchforks and torches uh
but she was like who was that who's that
woman you were talking to in the roses
and also that woman was stepping on my
fresh roses
guys have your conversations anywhere
else other than on my roses please
if i see your again i'll kill her myself
the train station's uh chaotic
and uh the family gets separated and
it's very sad uh najma stabs aisha uh
and then uh kamala shows up and we learn
it was a harry potter prisoner of
azkaban's situation mala was the one who
cast sonora light to save her
grandmother uh but uh you know the the
light disintegrated in a way that wasn't
just kamala a lot of people were helping
out uh there was uh qui-gon jin said a
footprints in this
[Laughter]
yeah
there was a there's another marty mcfly
over behind the train he's like
how do we help her
uh kyle reese was uh
trying to protect her he's like am i
loving a bunch of time travelers were
just there at that moment it's like this
is a nexus event for all of us
karachi station
that's right
um so back in the present uh the veil of
nora opens and then faria the
clandestine or should i say blandestine
there was someone who tweeted me about
this uh there was a couple people who
tweeted me about this i
uh i'm sorry this i cannot claim credit
for blandestine some other people have
recommended the nameplate last time and
i think it's great but yeah they tried
to pass through it but she chose paulie
and she turned into this chunky statue
for him before he wrote into a skeleton
and i gotta say
the the chunky state did look a bit like
a terrigen cocoon if you ask me i just
think it's an interesting choice one too
yes i i don't know if that's that was
the intention it just did looks very
similar
uh
yeah
now najma is ready to do the same uh but
kamala's like but you're leaving behind
cabaret and najman's like who
she's like you have this son
and she's like i don't i don't follow i
don't know who that is like
you could just tell uh
you could tell cody that uh wherever he
is he's fine because she was giving
camera the treatment that cameron gave
brian aka bruno um but then i guess
suddenly she cared about cameron again
and as she died she's like mmm cameron
you received my power now and then her
nor light uh kind of just zips through
the world and finds cameron who now has
uh his own nor big fist right so he has
her power now uh because comics i i but
not no i mean that's not what happens in
the comics at all
he has his powers like he has in the
comments yes he does have power yeah his
power is very different than uh than
kamala khan's powers so but essentially
now in this it's the same thing oh yeah
it's it's part of his body like he
doesn't need the bracelet right right
right right um so muniba uh gets there
pretty quick she uses the magical find
my phone
i do i mean i just love the actress who
plays moonee but she's like why am i
just scared about it i didn't enjoy that
moment that was quite funny i thought
that was so sweet uh
finds her daughter realized she is the
uh jersey city superhero and the three
generations of khan women just make
their piece kamala says goodbye to karim
uh who gives her his red sash you really
are just seeing her costume uh pieced
together from the various relationships
she has and i think that's so wonderful
um i did like that moment when she said
goodbye that kareem was like the u.s
government might arrest me and i might
be in thunderbolts who knows
right right yeah
he's like it depends and he turns to the
camera and says if you want me to be
arrested by the us government call this
number text
write your letters
tweet using this hashtag we need this i
need to keep working i mean hey i think
rama's knight was great in the show i
wouldn't mind seeing him again
it was just a little thirsty a little
thirsty at that moment
um
so uh maniva finds kamala's necklace
remember this is a necklace that had her
name written in urdu and it's now bent
to form the ms marvel logo kind of
teasing the last component of the
costume probably going to be uh uh
muniba stitching something together to
put that right
her outfit and then um kymeron seeks
some help from bruno gets his name right
finally uh
realizes he doesn't really get who
nikola tesla is but it appreciates the
word play of argonne good for you
uh and then a stark drone appears
outside the window oh cameron blast it
uh but then that drone just says well fu
man and then close up the entire circle
cue store committing domestic terrorism
in jersey city didn't even hit the floor
they were on just like screw your
business
i'll hit you where it hurts your wallet
and that's where we leave this episode i
gotta say pacing-wise this episode was
kind of like
is that is there more that that's it
like i think in general but we see this
pretty much every every disney plush
show so far the penultimate episode or
the episode four sometimes it's just
kind of like certain episodes certain
storylines get reworked i i just think
pacing wise it was
fascinating but also just uh a little
odd i think to spend so much time with
aisha and hassan uh i mean i look i'm
not gonna complain i think the acting
was great i think the writing was
beautiful it's just this story is about
kamala and i think it's okay to show her
her great-grandparents uh it's just we
have also been told the story so much
like this show was
an execution been so much about the the
partition that like we have lost sight a
little bit of kamala's journey um but i
don't know i think that's a minor gripe
overall it's just kind of like a
preference thing i just i think part of
it was i loved kamala in jersey city so
much me too that like
the more we've moved away from it i've
just missed it i've just missed it
that's it but i just feel like
personally for me anyway like the the
the interpersonal connections in jersey
city were a lot
more fun to explore than like the
friends that she met in pakistan which
is like i did love red dagger but like i
just feel like we could have got a
little bit more like
you know chemistry between the people
that she met which just felt like all
right i need to go from here to here and
like i'm meeting and like obviously like
it was really quick and she was meeting
all these people but like i just really
would have liked like some really fun
like all right i remember this character
from pakistan like
i i want to feel like i want to go back
to like i want marvel studios to go back
to pakistan and be like oh yeah i miss
all these people that i met in miss
marvel but like i didn't really feel
that way um but i do want to see more
red dagger anyway that's me but i think
if you're like um normally in tv shows
when they plot out their seasons and
their series the the pakistan arc would
be something that they do in season two
probably but i think you know the
writers on this show probably felt well
we don't know if we're gonna get a
season two of this this is our one
chance to really tell everything we want
to tell in this story so let's do it
let's just put it all in these six
episodes so and they may be right like a
lot of these disney plus shows these
marvel shows are not getting second
season in fact most of them are not
other than loki and what if right so
yeah i think that's just kind of the
reality they're working in and it has
led to just some uh unusual pacing and
tonal shifts uh on this show but overall
if they do get a season two i really
hope they go back to pakistan and like
really just flesh it out because like i
really like the look of pakistan i just
wish i just we spent more time with the
people i guess
yeah um all right so the time travel
that's where we're going to be talking
about this episode how the time travel
works did ms marvel dickham allicon
break the mc's time travel logic
i don't know about that but uh we'll
talk about that in a bit our merch
partners still have a limited number of
ms marvel inspired latest obsession
shirts cosmic daydream available at
nrockstarsmerch.com it's the best way to
support us here at new rockstars and
when you get one of these you will
unlock the added option to write in a
custom shout out that will appear at the
bottom of these after shows for example
we got william asking what if the hard
light is the cocoon that kamala is in
and will break out of to reveal her true
powers william you and i were once on
the same page and still are i wish that
is the case i'm just saying
don't hold your breath
i don't think that's where this show is
going i think they have uh
uh especially seen kamala khan in that
cruise line video her powers still look
like in big and nor in hard light it
seems like that is pretty much what
it's going to be if there's any cocoon
scenario it's going to be like that that
weird pterogenesis thing that we saw at
the end of this episode like it just i
feel like they might be setting up
terror genesis with this story of the
nor and all that stuff but um yeah i
don't think that like if any cocoon's
gonna happen it's gonna be that but like
i don't think that the the cocoon that's
in her bracelet is what's gonna um be
giving your powers like that they may
they may call it pterogenesis they may
use that word i just don't think uh that
theory that i had at the beginning of
this season that uh the the hard light
we're seeing as it is is like the cocoon
shedding away over the course of the
episodes
so far at least that has not been the
case on this show
um but that's okay i don't need my
theories to be right i prefer
this this show at the very end of the
day the show is i feel going to be an
origin story for those stretchy powers
and like what we're seeing is like what
the components of those stretchy powers
are it's the the cosmic energy
underneath those stretchy powers so when
something happens and i think that it's
going to be happening when she gets that
second bangle
she's going to have all the energy she
needs to like stretch but that's just my
weird theory
i mean i hope so too mt i just don't
think that's the case i i think that uh
i i don't want to get my hopes up
anymore like because you know i've run
and i've run into this with like one
division and all these other patches
we've covered where i've gone to the
final episode being like maybe this time
maybe this time
i don't want to feel that way next week
i kind of just like kind of i'm already
making peace with the fact that
the way they're doing kamala khan in the
mcu is is just this version of noir uh
and sometimes her fists can get bigger
as a result of it or sometimes her limbs
can stretch as a result of having this
nord power but that is
that's just the choice they've gone with
and i think they were hoping that after
these six episodes we'd better
appreciate the history of it uh and and
let's just be okay with that
i don't know i i think they are they
have missed out i think that is uh i
think ultimately
i definitely would have preferred kamala
khan to just have the the reed richards
uh scott lang like i can embig in and i
can stretch my body parts because i just
i think they had the technology for it
they could have done it um but
it's fine i'm not gonna get mad at the
show as a result of it
like what we got so far
yeah uh the characterization i think is
made the characterization the the
history of the characters the world that
they built i just think is really
beautiful and really cool um uh let's
see haley says kamala needs to meet
carol or monica this season before the
marvels please now i think that is a
hope you can cling to ahead of the
finale i i wouldn't be surprised if
neither brie larson nor tiana paris show
up in the finale i i i think there's a
good chance we'll see at least one of
them yeah like i really i think that you
know because we know that when amman
valani got the call that she was going
to be miss marvel she got a call
directly from brie larson's like hey
congratulations like you are part of the
marvel squad so i feel like carol is
probably gonna show up because like this
is a show
basically after her legacy so like she's
gotta show up
uh yeah and then mark asks when are they
introducing blade
uh
in a trailer at comic-con hopefully i
don't think it's gonna happen on this
show
i mean it might happen on this i was
thinking about this like last night i
was like hey like we have like all these
british soldiers and like looking after
this like bengal what if um
what's his face black knight's uncle
like his whole family like was like has
the bracelet because like they were
archaeologists if i'm not mistaken i
don't know what they did i forget what a
black knight's uncle was all about but
like uh he has all these old um
artifacts i'm like what if he has the
bangle and like because he's british and
he's like he just has the bengal um
anyway i like that theory that uh i i i
do like that theory that uh dane
whitman's uncle has has the other bengal
yeah like blade is just like all right i
took it from mr whitman then i have a
bagel now
uh yeah we'll see i just don't know how
much time they're going to make to set
up like uh vampire hunters in the mcu
right on this show i think that might be
something we'll see on uh
on she-hulk right like because it seems
like a case of the week kind of thing i
can imagine there being a vampire's
episode there d-o-d-c arrests and some
werewolves
yeah all right let's dive into this
episode mtv what's our question all
right brother did miss marvel break the
mcu's time travel logic yes
but the mcu's time travel logic was
already broken good night everybody
that's the end of the show thank you for
watching inside mt we learned a lot
about what we're all going through and
it's okay
we're all just doing everything
the post-credits scene of this episode
is just gonna be like a voice from the
shutter saying are you sure you're ready
for that
you'd be like
he's gonna be your wing man hey i would
love blade as my wig man especially
marshall ali are you kidding me
yeah
uh so this episode reveals that the
legendary trail of stars that saved
kamala's grandma during the partition
was actually cast by kamala herself
traveling back in time through a rift in
space time using her nor light to cast a
disc that broke apart into sparkles that
led this toddler back to her father so
how was kamala's grandmother saved it
was kamala herself
as someone who has made several videos
analyzing time travel and pop culture on
this channel mtu and i have done a past
episode of big question talking about
this um but this is what we have
identified as type four aka this always
happened time travel also known as
predestination or a closed loop in this
type of time travel mysterious anomalies
presented in the story early on
from the past are actually justified as
future doings of the protagonist going
back in time looping back to cause those
anomalies so this tends to blow the
minds of viewers that are less steeped
in time travel fiction
and whenever filmmakers or tv producers
whip it out in their stories they assume
that they are the only ones who have
ever done it and that will all be super
impressed and you know what to their
credit many people are super impressed
by it or at least very emotionally
affected because this tends to be the
weepier version of time travel like oh
this this mysterious thing i've always
wondered it was me all along or some
loved one all along and i didn't
actually have to do that much if i had
just opened my eyes and saw what was
right in front of me the whole time so
there's some sort there's like a bit of
a narrative catharsis that comes with it
but i will say it is now the most common
trope in time tribal fiction not all
tropes are bad uh but it is a trope and
we have to acknowledge that so
terminator how is john connor conceived
to one day lead the human resistance
against the machines well kyle reese
went back in time to protect sarah
connor his mother but actually fell in
love with her and conceived john to
begin with making that a closed loop
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
the mysterious patronus that saves harry
and sirius black from the dementors oh
it was not cast by harry's father it was
harry himself looping back to that
moment closed loop game of thrones why
does hodor say hodor well bran warg
through time to a stable boy's mind to
make him hold the door in the present
scrambling that person's mind for the
rest of their life closed loop
christopher nolan's tenant we thought it
was gonna be something different it did
try to be fancier about time travel but
it essentially boiling down to a movie
where lots of confusing anomalies
occurred throughout the plot that are
later revealed to be future versions of
these characters rewinding past them in
time a closed loop ryan johnson's looper
the rainmaker becomes a villainous uh
[ __ ] because his future victim tries
to go back in time to kill him as a kid
a closed loop netflix series dark does
this i also like to reference james
mangle too jackman romcom kate and
leopold does this
i know it seems like a rom-com but it is
the guy who ended up making logan and uh
is going to be making the next indiana
jones movie james mangold uh and hugh
jackman those two first working together
the first time without them we would not
have the wolverine and we would not have
logan a time travel movie my friends was
the reason behind all of it
um so in all of these stories everything
unfolds upon one fixed timeline a
character's active time travel itself is
destined uh and they arguably and this
is where it gets a little confusing they
do not have free will if you start to
think about this too much um and kamala
choosing to time travel to save her own
grandmother was it really a choice or
was it always destined to happen if
kamala exists to begin with right
because if she if her grandmother was
not safe kamala would not exist so it is
kind of destined for her to go back in
time it was not an accident it was not a
choice it was scripted as some car some
kind of like destination plot
um
so uh avengers in game initially sought
to define a different form of time
travel logic in the mcu you remember all
the arguments that they had about time
travel in the first and second act of
the movie initially it was going to be
what we call type 2 time travel aka
branch reality time travel this is
actually the explanation of time travel
posed by theoretical physicists
multiverse philosophers uh this is why
the russo brothers cited it in end game
uh but this theory poses that if someone
were to go back in time they would not
live within history as it unfolded the
way marty mcfly does they would actually
create a new branch timeline and an
alternate reality and this seems to be
the case in end game until the final
scene when old steve rogers appears by
the lake and the initial implication of
that moment was that old steve was in
the mcu the whole time just in the
background living out his life doing
nothing to prevent jfk's assassination
or 911 from happening um but he was
always there a kind of form of this
always happened time travel this is what
the screenwriters to this day claim they
want us to interpret the final scene of
endgame as uh but the russo brothers
disagree on that interpretation they
claim that old steve must have come from
an alternate timeline to stay true to
the movie's logic leading up to that
which just means that this old man uh
suited up in some kind of quantum suit
and is like
beat me down there hank pym or something
i don't know wherever he was
this old man
was
stay stable enough and sturdy enough
that he could survive some kind of weird
uh parallel timeline
yeah that's what it is dude i mean hey
hey keeps it keeps you going for years
um but i would say in that moment just
that disagreement between the
screenwriters and the directors and the
fact that many people are still debating
that i think that was really the moment
mcu timeline uh time travel logic was
just broken uh and it's okay like
obviously we're all still okay with this
and the great thing about loki is it
just kind of double down on the
confusing interpretations and the
unclear understanding of what timelines
and time travel is supposed to look like
in the mcu but at least according to the
tva only certain decisions made by
certain individuals cause branch
timelines to form decisions in violation
of the arbitrary sacred timeline that
was prescribed by he who remains so it's
only like if he has a script for how
history and destiny is supposed to go if
just like certain people
go off script that's what causes branch
timelines and then tva agents can appear
in and out of various points in history
but uh rather than causing new branch
timelines to form the tva erase their
tracks by detonating a reset charge to
erase that branch altogether history
within the sacred timeline is just
considered fixed and unchangeable uh and
monitored and maintained by the tva
predestined like apocalyptic events like
the destruction of haven hills or
lamentis are destined to happen no
matter who time travels back to those
days before the destruction happens it
happens because that's how he remains
wants it to happen so in some ways that
did ignore avengers end game
and set us back in type 4 this always
happened the sacred timeline unraveled
into a multiverse one might argue
because that is what he remains planned
to happen you know we still don't really
know fully what jonathan major's subtext
was in that monologue but it did seem
like he intended on something happening
by the end of that he was a little
surprised to be going off script but i
think he that was part of his plot it
was like an inevitability that the
multiverse was going to unravel into
that spider webby fracturing like he he
knew that silvie wasn't going to take
charge of the tva because like she hated
the tbs he was like hey just kill me
because multiverse is going to give you
messed up anyway this is my plan
right i think that was part of his game
is he was presenting a false choice to
sylvia loki so the events of ms marvel
are understood to occur within the
sacred timeline uh earth 616. i'm sorry
iman valani i know you disagree with
kevin feige that this universe is 616.
but it is his call to make not yours
loki the show even indicated that the
main mcu timeline is 616 because the
film strip in episode 1 showed the
events of infinity ward end game the
same ones kamala recapped in the episode
one of this series that film trip was
labeled 616. right so
knowing all this there are three ways at
least we can interpret what kamala just
did on the show and how this time travel
logic connects to the mcu
first takeaway this show might just be
doing its own thing and the writers and
producers don't really give a crap how
time travel worked in endgame or loki
they just want this to be as
thematically impactful as possible with
kamala's family origin story which is i
think it's totally fine to just kind of
like give it a pass on that one the
second interpretation that i think still
works logically is that kamala's bengal
might have opened a rift in space time
and that that act was an incursion
between timelines
so when sylvia and loki unraveled the
sacred timeline one timeline we saw
those branches going in all different
directions even connecting back on
themselves one timeline in this case
bent backward on itself and allowed
kamala to travel back to that night in
1947. so we've seen incursions taking
place between universes like in
multiverse of madness between realms
like what waleed was worried uh warning
about and arguably what we saw in
chongqi
uh and then now we're seeing incursions
between timelines so that's like a one
interpretation of what we saw the third
interpretation third takeaway is that
the mcu may be declaring that when time
travel occurs via human technology like
stark tech pymtek the lesser advanced
technology of the mcu uh it causes
branch timelines to form and that's
because it's like
imperfect still sloppy technology but
when time travel occurs via advanced
technology what we what we see is magic
like the technology of nathaniel
richards from the 31st century or these
bengals or the time stone that that form
of technology allows the time travel to
be fixed and predestined on a closed
loop a cleaner version of time travel so
essentially the more advanced the
technology the cleaner the time travel
less likely the branches form
i don't know if that's going to be the
case i don't know if uh at any point on
a show they're gonna bother to go that
far right um but i do think the
at least one or two uh is a way one way
that we can look at it i guess the
question i want to ask you about mt if
loki pre-stat uh if loki established all
the events of the mcu as predestined up
until that point uh and logic that will
at least continue to be a precedent
considering we are getting a second
season of loki are we meant to see the
bengal opening the rift in time as an
accident like just something that the
bengal a power that the bengal had that
people didn't really know it could do or
was this a destined stimulus of an
incursion seen from within that timeline
an example of how he remains planned for
the sacred timeline to fraction and
unravel creating these overlaps and
closed loops in order to get characters
on the path that they are meant to be on
yeah i feel like all of this is because
of he who remains like and when i say
all this i mean like spider-man no way
home this series like all the weird [ __ ]
that is happening in the mcu in terms of
like time travel and timelines and
wormholes opening up it's all he who
remains and i think that like this type
of time travel in the show probably
wasn't possible before loki i think that
after he remains freshened up sorry for
swearing um like he
completely just messed up like how time
travel works completely so that marvel
studios can do whatever they want with
time travel as they see fit without
having to adhere to the the rules that
they set in endgame so it's just like
hey like we're not going to constrain
all of our writers because like yeah
like it was a very interesting thing
that we did in engage but like time
travel logic and fiction is just
whatever so like let's just introduce
the chaos by killing the man who was
controlling time and uh do a lot of
weird [ __ ] um so yeah i think that um it
was because loki was a huge deal and
like the death of he remains um
definitely caused time travel to mess up
but in terms of like that what you asked
about the bengal i think that this could
actually be a function of the bengal
like uh traveling through different
timelines um because like we saw in um
this is just a weird theory of mine but
like we saw in an early episode of ms
marvel that um bruno mentions the sun
was the key to time travel and the crack
in um that opens up the uh when al kamal
comes back is has a golden tint like
it's very much sunlight-esque um when it
first opens up so i'm thinking like the
the bangle itself which is gold i think
that this gold is like the link to the
sunlight and like when she hit it it
activated the the crack it's like all
right time to go sunlight mode and um
you know that that is the key to um to
inter-dimensional travel like bruno sort
of into that but um yeah i think that
once she gets that second bangle she
might have the power to like just travel
through timelines just as a as a perk
that'd be really fun yeah i think what
we're seeing from the bengal i i think
that's really on point mt some very
interesting analysis of what you just
said and i think like the bengal is one
example of objects and technology of
immense power in the mcu and that just a
consequence of that power is that when
the border between realms timelines and
universes is already eroding that power
can blast through that and cause an
incursion and in this case i just think
we're seeing an incursion of time but
incursions can also take place between
space and could take place between
universes uh so between space would be
like between realms i think incursions
affect every tier of reality uh in the
mcu now one thing i just
want to tell everyone watching this and
i'm gonna we're gonna have to talk about
this a lot as we go forward in the mcu
do not expect any clear cohesive
explanation and interpretation of how
time travel works across these
properties because if you read marvel
comics i think you already have accepted
those low expectations because this is
exactly how the comics work there are
feuding logical explanations for how
time travel works and that's okay we
just have to live in that world and i
think uh it is kind of like we are uh
legal experts sifting through
hundreds of years of alternate
explanations of what a law means uh and
uh like there's various different legal
rulings uh and we're kind of saying well
what is
is there any kind of precedent that we
can establish like what was the framers
original intention
by the way these things were worded and
i think what we're able to at least
begin to surmise here if we're trying to
read kevin feige's mind and i think we
can safely conclude first off that
there is no dogmatic plan uh because
otherwise
you know there would be uh at least when
it comes to time travel because
otherwise people would be closely
sticking to the same words and repeating
the same rules over and over again and
instead i think kevin feige's giving
each uh screenwriter across multiverse
madness or loki or ms marvel a bit of a
loose leash on how they want to word
things and then that's creating a bit of
confusion and i think that confusion is
totally okay
um but i think the fact that both
avengers end game ended with old cap the
fact that loki ended with he who remains
saying that this is all part of a script
and now this show is showing a
closed-loop version of time travel i
think at least kevin feige and his team
sees the mcu as part of a
a scripted pre-destination
uh approach to time travel that things
have all things have happened the way
they are because that's how they are i
think we're going to learn more about
kang
the reason why things exist in the mcu
the way they are is because kang has
made them that way i think that's what
we can kind of expect going forward i
think that's the version of time travel
that is more exciting to kevin feige and
his team but i think we have to accept
that it does deny a certain amount of
free will from his characters and i
think maybe that free will was never
there like evan feige i think views
himself as a master clock maker and that
characters don't really chart their own
destinies uh that it was all part of a
plan
um now that does
uh you could argue fly in the face of
what we've seen with characters like
thor right they've been kind of on their
own journey and i think kevin feige has
kind of been okay with changing course
midstream with characters like thor and
letting them chart their own destinies
uh but i think he prefers to live in a
reality where
there is someone behind the strings who
is kind of positioning pieces in place
uh but trust us
but trust us
they're gonna get to where they need to
go
yes i think that's where we're at like i
mean i do trust kevin five because kevin
feig has done a really great job so far
with like steering the mcu and like even
though like
it is hard to see like uh like the the
time travel logic so far with the mcu
but i feel like at the end of the day
there is some type of mysterious plan
that we are not privy to there um but
like we're seeing this time travel from
different perspectives and so like
because we're seeing um like the um all
this weird [ __ ] happened from like you
know first from um
from loki's perspective and now we're
going from miss marvel's perspective i
just feel like the names and different
like terminologies for stuff are going
to be different because we're looking at
things from different perspectives so um
yeah i feel like
um it might seem like there might not be
a plan but like maybe this is
intentional by kevin feige to throw off
us throw us off the scent because we're
too damn good at our jobs eric he's just
like all right let's just let's use uh
synonyms and just trick eric and mtf um
makes it look like you don't have a plan
i would love if like he cared that much
i don't think that's the case i
genuinely think he uh he wants to put
some of the creative control in the
hands of these uh directors and and show
runners uh and i think like he's paying
a price for it a lot of the reviews for
phase four titles like even like thor
eleven thunder has like what a 75 i
think um like the fact that multiverse
of madness was not as universally
beloved like other than no way home i
don't think we've had like a facebook
title to where everyone just got on the
same page and said yes
like i mean some of the disney plus
titles maybe loki and one division i
think everyone for the most part was
cool with but like
i don't know i just also remember
hearing a lot of like backlash against
wanda vision some backlash against loki
but i think that's ultimately all for
the best um because it's also given us
an opportunity to see some really bold
uh production design and storytelling
like phase four even though it's not
like universally beloved it's like we're
seeing some fascinating imagery in this
space that we whereas phase three i
would argue a lot of those movies looked
a lot like each other like if you didn't
know the characters uh age of ultron and
winter soldier and civil war all kind of
look like the same movie in a lot of
ways yeah no like i feel like you know
towards like the as we approach endgame
and infinity war like a lot of people
were demanding that marvel do something
different because like all their stuff
sort of felt like very similar in in
terms of tone and all that so like phase
four what i really appreciate is that
like they're giving us the different
like we we've gotten so many different
types of things in phase four them it's
like wow like this feels like a fully
fleshed out like mcu where like we're
just seeing different tones and
different types of people that i'm just
like yeah like this is like marvel
studios sort of sort of getting their
footing on trying new things so like now
that we've had like phase four kick off
i feel like as things start to progress
things might get better because kevin
feige as we know from the past like 10
or over 10 years of marvel he learns
from his mistakes and like he learns
from from experience so like this is his
experience and like the things that
we're going to get in the future um are
going to be better in response to what
people have been saying on these reviews
and stuff so like kevin feige listens
for sure yeah
um he's always listening right like
you're right microphones everywhere he's
here
all right we have a couple more
questions we want to ask about this
episode but first we want to thank rakon
for sponsoring this episode if you're
listening to inside marvel right now as
a podcast are you listening with raycon
earbuds because uh when i'm out and
about in the world that's how i consume
my daily podcast diet raycon's everyday
earbuds look and feel and sound better
than ever with optimized gel tips for
the perfect in-ear fit their earbuds are
super comfortable and they fit better
than some antique bangles that your
grandmother sent you in the mail raycons
offer three sound profiles to match what
you're listening to plus noise isolation
and awareness mode so that you can
choose to be immersed in sound or be
able to hear your surroundings when you
need to i really like them around the
house like when i'm making dinner or
doing chores they're just super secure
they sound great raycons give you eight
hours of play time and a 32-hour battery
life you can even do wireless charging
with raycon so you can get the same
quality audio as other premium audio
brands but at half the price it's no
wonder raycon's everyday earbuds have
over 49 000 five-star reviews check out
raycon's wireless earbuds my guess is
that you're gonna want to leave them a
five-star review too go to buyrecon.com
marvel today to get 15 off your recon
order that's by raycon.com marvel to
score 15 off that's by raycon.com marvel
all right empty back to ms marvel let's
talk about this moment that najma
transfers her powers into comrade what
exactly were we looking at in that
moment how did she do that and uh what
exactly did she do i i actually spent
like an hour last night re-watching that
moment like a zillion times um and i i
came to the conclusion that
the first person that went through the
portal
i think it worked i think that she
actually got back to her dimension and
that her dimension as we saw in the
previous episode is looks dramatically
different from from um 616. like i feel
like everybody in that dimension is pure
energy oh
so when this woman went through the
portal her energy went through the
portal thus making the of the portal
bigger and worse so but like najma it
was like all right now it's my turn
because like my friend went through the
portal and she's fine and like and since
like her our universe is much different
we don't have flesh and bones so like
we're gonna drop this off on the ground
here because like we don't need this in
our universe and so like it's my turn
now she was which is why natural said
that she can make it because like that
was the whole plan it's like hey i don't
care about what happens to reality i can
make it because i am an energy being
however since kamala said don't leave
cameron behind she was like you know
what you're right i'm going to close
this portal by having my body be
destroyed and becoming of my my original
nor energy self but instead of going
through the portal i'm going to go into
my son and so basically kymeron has the
power of her mother who is with her like
her mother his mother never left it's
like she's this is basically her trying
to
atone for leaving cameron behind by
being the source of his power um which
is what i think is going on here that's
such an interesting theory empty you get
a golden sparkle log
a roblox all right
you did it they were just here i was
waiting to hear the right the right
theory you did
the only the only uh difference i i
think might have happened was rather
than them being made of uh pure energy
in the nord dimension
all we saw was just their bones so maybe
like all their flesh like their skin and
their muscle tissue it's just like jelly
just kind of sloshing around you're like
we don't need bones
back home
oh my god
where was that dimension to multiverse
and madness
um
it's a paint dimension yeah you remember
yeah i i hope that like the the big
chunky form that they took like
the the the key master and the
gatekeeper from ghostbusters i hope that
that was like i would love if that's a
terror genesis cocoon i just think that
would be a weird time for the cocoon to
show up like it just seemed like
something that encased their body and
then like killed them yeah i wonder if
like the reason why that happened is
that could have been like
a security measure that the other
clandestines in the north dimension were
like you if you ever try to return
this is like their security measure to
keep people out and they don't want that
kid that's a really good idea because
they were prisoners or exiles rather or
we could just be seen like the like an
indiana jones style like this is the
consequence and like or maybe originally
like their bodies were supposed to get
like torn to pieces and all that was
left as a skeleton and they're like this
is a little too dark so let's like kind
of put a what's it called a vanity cover
over over their body
torn and then we'll just see a skeleton
on the other side something like that i
think but i love your theory i i um like
just to be clear cameron in the powers
isn't inhuman the way kamala is he gets
hit with the terrigen mist i don't think
we're seeing
mist necessarily i think this show just
basically swapped out target missed for
nor light and kind of invented this new
mechanic and then so like the way that
kamala has the nor light that was
activated by the bangle in this case it
was activated by i guess his mother's
dying wish uh to transfer her powers
over to him i think it is a little fuzzy
to be honest i think if we were to ask
the at some point the producers the
directors are gonna like have their
answer and it's probably not gonna be
satisfying i think they're going to be
like writing is hard
but you know what if like what if
there's a possibility here that like the
creed themselves discovered these
bangles as we saw like the bangle on a
blue arm in a previous episode what if
they discovered these bangles and were
like yo what is this weird um stuff
coming out of this crack in the universe
let's take that and do science on it and
make terrigen mist out of it because
like we don't really know what this is
so it's like let's experiment on this um
and like that's maybe where we're
looking at the very source of the
territories science with these cracks
yeah i mean that'd be cool especially
like uh since we know there's an
intersection between astrophysics and
like cosmic technology and the like
exploration of alternate dimensions just
based off of eric selvig's research that
bruno did eric selvig you know reads
things uh researches things like
einstein rose and bridges and the way
the cosmos connects in his underwear
he's also firmly aware from like the
convergence
into alternate dimensions and alternate
realms so i think that uh there could be
an intersection there like the cree are
aware of like alternate browns alternate
dimensions and they've been trying to
tap into it as well and that could be
something
why they created the bengal to begin
with yeah that could be the case i like
the theory here you get another you got
another spark
thanks
nice
we have a little bit of time here we
have one more episode left how do you
think this is all going to end mt what
do you think what are your hot takes for
the final episode hmm i feel like at the
end of this episode we're gonna see
kamala fight with kamran for some reason
um and they're gonna come to blows and i
think that kamala is going to
when she gets that second bracelet um in
this sixth episode hopefully um she's
going to have a similar type of energy
to cameron and i think that the symbolic
messaging behind the bracelets is that
um the
her first bangle is her is aisha and her
second bangle will represent uh najma
and like the two bengals together will
like form like a reconciliation
symbolism between the two uh the two
women and so um i think that when she's
gonna get that second bangle and it's
gonna probably glow somewhat similarly
to um
to cameron but that's just my weird
theory what do you think is gonna happen
i mean it seems like the by the way
episode five ended it looks like they're
just setting up a battle with the dodc i
i honestly think kamal and cameron are
going to team up against uh was it uh uh
deever from the dodc deeper
the true villain yeah which is kind of
lame but i think that is the case right
like she's the last villain that we know
of unless we re unless it's revealed
that someone else is behind the dodc or
that dodc agent is there's more to her
like she could be part of the cree
sleeper cell or something like that i
think that'd be my preference if this
does link up with like the cree coming
to earth as opposed to just like a
government agency because in some ways
it feels like a de-escalation from the
from the clandestine so um but i think
that's how it's going to go i think this
is going to set up both the marvels and
she-hulk uh i think the marvel's i think
we'll get some answer about where the
bengal came from hopefully they'll
they'll establish that it's greed tech i
don't think we're going to explore
further into the nord dimension
personally i i think this show has
answered all the questions it's going to
answer the fact that the gate closed and
that the clandestine are now all dead i
just don't think they're going to
explore further into that i think now
our answers are going to come from
the like where the bengal came from the
fact that it was screetech
what cree forces might be on earth now
how that's going to set up
she-hulk and secret invasion in the
marvels i think those are going to be
the answers and i think yeah i think i'd
be surprised if we didn't get a cameo
from brie larson or yeah
or just someone from sword you know
recruiting her i think
yeah i i think we're we're overdue some
kind of cameo there to explain that and
i would love it if we also saw a cameo
from like uh shang chi or wang like some
kind of explanation of what the rings
pulsing were all about like i think this
would be a great opportunity to answer
that question by just saying oh it's
it's a cree uh fleet headed to earth to
reclaim their tech and to kill all the
squirrels that are here yeah i i want to
see the ten rings appear at some point
in episode six because they teased them
earlier on so like we've got to see some
ten rings actually yeah i think they
could follow up on that for sure thank
you all for joining us for this episode
of uh of ms marvel after show inside
marvel here at new rockstars we'll leave
it there but we'll be back next week
again my easter egg breakdown is coming
out tomorrow not a lot of easter eggs
this episode but there were some
interesting like visual choices and and
song choices that i want to dig into so
i'm excited to break it down uh don't
forget to check out our great merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com follow
me at ea boss follow mt mastertainment
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
nmt i just want to say again
i would do inside mt with you every day
of the week i love i love being able to
connect with you and the only downside
of doing these shows is that we we have
to talk about some of the marvel shows
just talking about anything is such a
highlight of my week it's it's such a a
blessing to be able to connect with you
well thank you for joining me for inside
mt my friend i know but no i'm just
legit like i love doing it tomorrow with
you every week you're the best and uh i
can't wait to do this with you next week
man i'll see you next week mt love you
brother see ya bye
you